let's take a quick look at how to create  custom compute engine instances open  your Google Cloud dashboard and go to  the compute engine section now click  create instance here you can see the  customized link you can customize the  number of CPU cores as well as a  gigabytes of memory for your instance  once you've selected all the appropriate  options scroll down and click create in  a few seconds your custom vm should be  created  you can also create a custom vm using  the g-cloud tool run g-cloud compute  instances create then give it the name  of your new instance and now you can use  the dash dash custom CPU flag followed  by the number of CPU cores and the dash  dash custom memory flag followed by the  gigabytes of memory in a few seconds you  can see your new VM